buongiorno ragazzi che ci crediate o no
benvenuti e bentornati a una puntata di
cui cita buttata oggi proveremo ancora
non lo so perché non ho ingredienti in
questi giorni sto facendo pochissima
spesa
sto cercando di uscire il meno possibile
di casa mi sto nutrendo leccando il
pavimento quindi quello che farò molto
probabilmente sarà aprire niente mi
scrivono vivi come scrive qualcuno chi è
mio fratello come come se avesse scritto
quello che farò quindi sarà aprire la
mia dispensa e sperare che alcuni avanzi
di ingredienti di cucina buttata al
passato possano in qualche modo comporre
un piatto quale perché molto
probabilmente lo vedrete nella tamed
questo video nel quale io ancora non ne
ho idea né coscienza iniziamo subito a
cercare sa cos'è che vuole lì ma che
qualcosa cosa sei
lo vedete lo vede lo vede si vedo già
una cosa farina quindi sicuramente la
farina la usiamo su che affaccia un
dolce o zucchero lievito di ma ce
l'avevo il lievito io quindi per potermi
fare il pane da solo no no no vabbè che
svolta lievito per dolci pure of
cioccolata come non faccia perché sto
facendo la colazione presidente con
l'acqua frizzante cereali cacao
zuccherato in polvere interessante che
cos'è questo vanillina ragazzi siano
assolutamente di dolce gelatina in fogli
sì ma non faccia cose quello cacao amaro
mazza ragazzi al cacao ma sollievo al
programma ma quanto caco fatemi fare una
ricerca al volo su internet di un nuova
che non o almeno non lo so non mi sforzo
ma che rinasce qualcosa circa 15
frullini 15 la linea da buoni per uno
stuzzichino ruolo di lucro perché ha un
burro lievito gocce di cioccolato
fondente non ci trova bene ma li faccio
senza gocce di cioccolato fondente
allora sto prendendo la ricetta di un
sito che si chiama ricetta puntoit
suggerisce di farlo anche con le gocce
di cioccolato che io non ho ma non so
che cosa altro fare
quindi seguirò questa preparazione per
cui avremo bisogno di farina zucchero
semolato cacao amaro in polvere farina
burro farina lievito per dolci con
questo video è sponsorizzato da zucchero
semolato acqua lievito per dolci e gocce
di cioccolato
non ce l'ha con questa ripresa che è una
ripresa che forse fa solo un ginecologo
molto probabilmente sistema subito che
cosa andremo a fare prendiamo una una
boule che effetto fa in camera se faccio
questo sembrano veramente facile e
veloce questa preparazione setaccerà
farina
no io non ho setaccio cosa che poi in
realtà se uno ci pensa è molto meglio
fare così ciechi svuoti la dispensa di
tutte cose che magari più o meno ai ora
lascia stare magari non ci mette il
cacao lancio è presente le maglie burro
morsi però sono comunque cose abbastanza
reperibili se ce l'ho io a 130 g
siri fortuna non tirano 100 100 g di
fortuna ho già esagerato mettiamo 130
grammi di farina per questi qui che
chiameremo i biscotti della quarantena
ho deciso aggiungiamo la fortuna che
cavolo e setaccio a pesare 20 grammi
cacao solo 20 dirci quanto pesa poco no
e messi 22 rovesti cavoli 22 e non messi
perché le voglio più cioccolatosi un
bisogno d'affetto lo zucchero che sono
solo 50 gr ci sono 50 grammi ma questi
che sapranno di morte 49 quaresima
va bene mesi 50 48 grammi di lievito
io odio pesare tre buste per complessivi
36 grammi grazie devo fare la matematica
quindi 12 e quindi non trasmettere
occhio 8 grammi così ecco fotogramma
scusate tutto occhio ragazzi che se le
si avvicina il gatto c'è kakà dentro
perché sembra una lettiera in questo
momento non poter nemmeno capire la
difficoltà che io nel girare tutte
queste cose da solo
mancano quei maledetti che mi manca
avere dei disturbatori in cucina perché
almeno erano utili fallo a 70 g di burro
che non
quanto sia questo 96 non voglio perdere
la vita oggi trovano integra nemmeno
questo sì sì sì 70 grammi tanto qui non
c'è nessuno che mi vuol dire il vero
quello che dico io è legge oggi vivono
ad aggiungere a pezzettini in modo che
poi più facile amalgamare il problema
mio e che è veramente freddo
chiederò una botta di microonde ragazzi
per fortuna ci sono per dirle queste
cose che la ricetta puntoit sito
validissimo è spesso siamo andati su
ricetta punto it per delle ricette punto
vieta appunto si scherzano veramente un
bacio e un grazie a ricetta punto it
senza la quale non avrei avuto nella
colazione è un contenuto mostrarvi là
dentro
nel mio meraviglioso forno a microonde
ad alta quota
lo lascio andare per 30 secondi nel
frattempo prendo l'acqua che sono 70 g
di acqua 70 g di acqua davvero si pesa
acqua ora come minimo gli scienziati mi
spiegheranno che tipo molto
probabilmente il volume e il peso
dell'acqua sono banali quelle cose che
non sai mai che qualcuno che arriva per
sapere se le mie riprese sono più
stabili di quello che mi fa enrico ha
aggiunto il burro ecco che lo faccio
vedere troppo tardi 70 grammi d'acqua
dio perché continua ad aggiungere che
schifo 71 e cinque sì esattamente quelli
che diceva una ricetta
mamma mia il brutto colore prendere il
cara con la farina degli scatti grigi
gandalf il grigio riscatti di gandalf
vabbè sporcare come cercare di stanare
un battere a mani nude
scusate non parli non dico niente ok
quando 0 che voi commenti a te non mi
serve dire altro
no sta cercando cercando di spegnere la
videocamera da solo maggior le mani
sporche ragazzi parliamo un attimo
seriamente dobbiamo una volta fatto
tutto avere questo che va messo in frigo
va fatto riposare per una mezz'oretta
sono meglio anche un po di più perché
comunque avendo una base di burro
proprio in frigo che cosa fa siri
solidifica e credo che se allo stesso
processo della pasta frolla che se la
lavori troppo scioglie il burro e quindi
poi diventa ingestibile lavorare da
questa roba
però ho un'idea siccome sto impazzendo a
caso io potrei anche uscire a fingere di
avere appena portato il cane che ha
avuto un attacco di sorta e viene quando
il cane scusi dov'è fido non lo trovo al
momento la butto un secondo questo lo
vado a riprendere in questo modo non
dovrei aver problemi
cioè mi faccio un giretto con questo in
mano no faccio i biscotti che meglio in
frigo timer 30 minuti eccoci qui in
realtà un'ora dopo
perché mezz'ora non bastava un sono
andato di a toccarlo e sembrava comunque
mi scrive ricerca devi farti scherzo del
mio amico torno al 6 prima che si pensi
sacchi dicevo in mezz'ora era ancora
cioè aveva mangiato più fibre però no
invece un'ora dopo commesso a riscaldare
il forno a 170 gradi quindi un'ora e un
quarto
adesso abbiamo questa palla che cercherò
di lavorare il più velocemente possibile
vi faccio vedere cosa faccio testo non
prendo faccio se palline e poi piazzo
qui secondo me c'è un errore con
ingredienti è troppo molle ma è una
pecora che ha piazzato su strada questo
quel risultato finale prende una pecora
deve aver messo la vostra teglia ho il
terrore che si aprono un sacri che
quindi alla fine io mi troverò ad avere
un enorme tensione ma onestamente cosa
sta inquadrando loro dicono 10 15 minuti
facciamo dieci minuti per andare a
controllarli preghiamo ha intanto
aspettiamo questi dieci minuti dai dai
dai dai al tra poco tra poco tra poco un
piccolo aggiornamento siamo tipo a
quattro minuti c'è un odore di vino
nell'aria
allora di tutto nel frattempo piccolo
update gli occhiali perché da superman
sono tornato clark kent ho fatto un
procedimento dopo dieci minuti ancora
non erano ottimali o schiacciati in con
un cucchiaio infatti vedere non so se
notate male sono più piatti adesso nel
nostro anzi più globuli rossi globuli
bianchi rilievi globuli sono apparati
presenti quelli che sembrano le
preservativi che vanno ancora di noi di
fare comunque questo quindi adesso do
altri 5 minuti
vediamo un pò occhio cioè l'alta
pasticceria si fa anche un po così a
occhio ragazzi non vi posto insegnare 28
eccolo eccolo fammi riprendere mentre
200 questo ti riprendi non succede come
se non fosse successo st d'anna leggero
e corretto a roma di bruciato sento
questo è ancora molliccio dentro altri
tre minuti funzionano i biscotti tre
minuti tre minuti una canzone un ascolto
una canzone tanto tutte le canzoni
promesso di tre minuti
anzi mi sono appena ricordato che per
motivi di copyright non posso ascoltare
canzoni quindi dovrò comporre una
canzone nel frattempo che è la cosa che
più mi diverte in questo periodo di
quarantena quarantina una canzone
voglio mangiardi
[Musica]
ma di pecora
mangiare
mangiardi per trasformarvi in tacco ma
stava per cadere sta per cadere questa
cosa fa per fare lo stronzo detto subito
guardate vado a controllare i miei
biscotti checa di pecora comunque
ragazzi veramente sto scoprendo un
talento che già sapevo di avere in
passato non sono quale non ho mai voluto
puntare a mese ma sempre della stessa
cosa non so poi podio guardando i miei
video calcolando quanto sono originale
direi che da anni mi sembra di vedere la
stessa cosa
leggermente morbidini ma stacco il forno
e lo lascio a raffreddare vabbè oppure
il mio allenamento fisico di ragazzi
dovrei far vedere cosa mi sta uscendo
qua sotto al limite di maggio dopo il
riordinamento se no se faccio in tempo
chi mangia appena prima così o
dell'energia sono da prendere con i più
piccoli tutti guardate il carino che e
fatte vedere tronto assaggiamo lo mi sto
nutrendo leccando il pavimento canto non
so fare un orto e pulito del capro per
terra
successivamente friabili faccio un
secondo assaggio più tardi per vedere
quando sono un pochino piuttosto ok come
potete vedere dalle illuminazioni è
notte mi sono allenato ho fatto er
coatto dj sul balcone c'era pure il
compleanno di andy ormai io vicini non
mi sono mai pagato in vita mia di colpo
migliori amici
per fortuna c'è la pandemia per unirci
cercherò anche di far vedere delle scene
e meravigliose di se non avete già visto
su instagram vigente tirava i pacchi
cose così in fette di torta e venivano
passate le faccio vedere nel blog che
esce dopodomani martedì è arrivato per
ora il momento ora sono interessanti
sono decisamente interessanti flash
zucchero a velo e se si ha avuto dolci
cioccolato questione ancora più buono
quanti sono fatto 15 mini 16mi magno
tutti è andata qualcuno lo facciamo di
forza rispettiamo queste regole
stiamo veramente tutto lo staff in il
prima possibile ci vediamo martedì con
un nuovo video
sempre su questo canale alle 12 ciao